foreign
in
Seattle lately man home of the grunge
movement what's up Kristen how we doing
good how are you good are you just
thinking about Pearl Jam and Nirvana
this morning is that what you do in
Seattle when you wake up it's just I
don't know
no I I'm not the typical Seattle person
that's my favorite answer of the day are
you just waking up thinking of Pearl Jam
in Nirvana and you just go no no no no
celebrate Christian I I I do have to say
I love the men shed thing I I think
there's something to say about creating
a space where people can do things while
they open up and talk because I think
it's so it's not intimidating and I
think more of that needs to be happening
I agree there's something about
um doing something with somebody that
makes it easier to have a conversation
than it does just putting your hands in
your lap and staring at somebody and
them saying tell me what's wrong with
your life and on that note Kristen tell
me what's wrong with your life
all right what's up no that's okay
um I have I have three teenagers
um ages 13 16 and 18. and my question is
um I'm also I've been divorced for five
years and so I understand my kids are
best served if they have healthy
relationships with both their dad and
myself
so how do I support and facilitate if I
am able to them having a positive
relationship with their dad
while at the same time helping them
understand what healthy relationship
boundaries look like when he's probably
not
healthy relationship and he's making
choices that don't create a healthy
relationship
you just said that in the most
eloquently evasive way I've heard in a
long time look you were very gifted at
that
um like I could get off the phone now
and feel really good and if someone's
like what did she say I would go I don't
know but it just sounded so nice so
let's get to the nitty-gritty
um here's what I think I heard
you got divorced five years ago and I'm
just gonna throw it out there you may
say you're an idiot you still aren't a
super fan of the divorce and your
husband is not being the dad that you
envisioned him being as a co-parent and
your kids are struggling
okay I
I am broken-hearted every single day
that I wrote a chapter of my kid's life
for them that they are now stuck with
um
and I think he is doing a terrible job
of parenting yeah there we go thank you
that's thank you for speaking English
that now I'm talking he sucks right all
right um and I'm I'm doing my best I
have
um I've encouraged them to have
conversations with him to identify the
problem help him figure out like can
they're missing out on quality time he
doesn't make time for them so can you
suggest can we go for a walk Dad can we
go for ice cream can we have a movie
night I've met with his new wife we've
had a conversation I've met with a
pastor in the church that he respects
about how to encourage a healthy
relationship with his kids there's
nothing I've done that it's helped him
make changes he needs to have good
relationships with his kids and I don't
know how to handle it as a supportive
co-parent on my behalf you have to open
up your hands and let that go
because that's your favorite that's your
fantasy not his
and I hate that for you Mike there's
there's nothing you can do
he is making a choice to not be involved
in his kid's life
and that's going to be his cross to
carry for a long long time
um you mentioned at the very beginning
the call the best thing for them you're
exactly right is two adults who lean in
and love their kids
um
your kids aren't going to get the best
and it's making peace with that
you you waking up every day and choosing
to live brokenhearted is adding more
bricks to their backpacks that they
don't need to carry
why do you you regret this you say you
don't regret it I disagree with you what
what is the baggage you're still
carrying do you wish y'all had worked it
out do you wish you'd stuck it out like
what are you hanging on to or you just
wish that you hadn't put your like what
what is it that you're upset with
yourself over
um that I created a divorced home for my
kids I I was in the marriage for 17
years it was very
um lonely there was never any emotional
intimacy there was never a friendship it
was very much me raising four kids on my
own basically being a single parent in
that marriage
um I do not regret leaving the
relationship I regret the heartache a
divorced home creeps for my kids
did you also regret the heartache that a
lonely isolated
spouse create
did you also Lament The Heart the
heartache that your kids are gonna have
to carry watching their dad act like a
grown-up child and forcing mom into a
parental role instead of a partnership
role like
you you made a choice a relational
choice because you couldn't survive
anymore
and yes that choice comes with
consequences no no mistaking that
but choosing something else would have
come with consequences potentially more
extreme ones
because your kids would have grown up in
a home so filled with tension and so
filled with angst and so filled with
rage that they would have spent all of
their time wondering what was wrong with
him because they felt insane at least
now they have something to point at
right
yeah and they've got a mom that loves
them like crazy Fair
absolutely and so the story of their dad
is unfolding in front of them
and we don't want this you don't I mean
this isn't something you would cheer for
or hope for
right but there will come a moment when
your kids if they haven't already go oh
okay
oh they're there okay right and here's
where that's dangerous for a kid
is you've probably heard me say this
before but they know that half of them
is that guy
and what if that turns out to be me what
is so bad about me why would my dad
choose fill in the blank other than
their kid like
they're searching for answers that have
logical conclusion I mean they're asking
questions that have logical answers and
they're not being met with logical
responses and it's just unnerving and
the best you can do is love them like
crazy
and we we talk about that a lot because
I've heard you say that quite often and
especially my 18 year old he doesn't see
his dad and he doesn't talk to his dad
anymore and he has said multiple times
I never want to be like him or I'm going
to make sticky notes and put him up on
my bathroom mirror when I have my own
place it says do not be your dad okay
here's here's where Mom you can really
help out
because what that's telling him is half
of me is dysfunctional and broken
and so I think it's hard but it's
important to say yeah there's some
things that I wish your dad was doing
differently I wish he's got I wish he
got to see what an awesome son you are
like I get to see and
your dad is really Charming in love and
funny and he can be really engaging and
he's got some good qualities too and by
lifting up the good parts of your
ex-husband you're lifting up your son
and that's really hard because it's easy
to just burn the whole guy to the ground
but you're burning your son to the
ground too and that happens
no and and I think it's trying to find
um those few good qualities
um and pointing them out and you know
saying okay it's a really good work
ethic and he passed that on to you and I
see that in you and so you have got some
really positive things here yes yes yes
yes and the things that you might see in
yourself that you don't like that are
like myself or your dad that you take on
simply because it's what you are modeled
you're you're capable of changing those
things too oh dude you're not a prisoner
to what you've been modeled and who your
parents are so good
I I you're in a season of discomfort and
so I almost hesitate to tell you this
but you're doing it exactly right
thank you you're doing exactly right um
you're making the best of a very messy
situation and I would if I'm in your
suit like the best I can tell you is if
I'm sitting in your seat
and my wife had left me and it's five
years later and she's remarried and
moved on with her life and suddenly she
doesn't want anything to do with the
kids
I would open my hands up and not try to
direct her behaviors I would try to use
that extra energy and love my kids I
would use that extra energy and love
myself enough just make sure I'm well
that I'm taking care of business that
I've got new relationships
um you can't take away your kids
questions about what they did to divide
up the home you can't take away your
kids questions about why their dad
doesn't want to spend time with them
that doesn't make any sense to them
um you can assure them there's not a way
they can act their way into their dad's
heart that right now he's making some
different decisions and it is it is it
stinks
but they're lovely and they're loved and
they're good kids
I would have your kids write your dad
their dad letters maybe make that a
weekly exercise
and what that will do for your kids is
it helps them begin to laser in on what
they miss
it really helps them come up with some
poignant questions and it keeps the
thoughts and feelings and emotions from
overwhelming a 13 or 18 or 16 year old
mind and body and so every week dad
won't talk to him dad doesn't want to
visit with him cool we're going to write
dad a letter and then they're going to
give them to you and you may not send
those letters you may just hang on to
them because this is going to be an
exercise for the home
um it's gonna be an exercise maybe they
read them out loud to you and they will
be heartbreaking
or maybe they're super fun or maybe
they're a mixture of both but it gives
your kids an outlet
it gives their bodies the opportunity to
speak to their dad when their dad just
won't speak to them
so that's just an idea
um maybe it's a once a month thing it
will be a painful exercise but it's an
exercise I think over time will really
benefit
um
and I'll just say this I know this goes
without saying but parents if you get
divorced you get divorced parents do
adults do adult things
show up for your kids
show up
for your kids